well by 2020 we'll have computers that
are powerful enough to simulate the
human brain but we won't be finished yet
with reverse engineering the UN brain
and understanding its methods one of my
main themes and and I've developed this
thesis over 30 years is that information
technology grows exponentially the power
of computers are understanding the human
brain the spatial resolution of
brain-scanning the number of bits we
move around the internet I mean many
different measures of information
technology double every one year or
every 11 months 13 months depending on
what you're measuring so these
technologies will be a million times
more powerful within 20 years 20 years
in fact the speed of exponential growth
is itself speeding up so in 25 years
these these technologies will be a
billion times more powerful than they
are today and we've already seen that
kind of progress when I was an
undergraduate we all shared computer at
MIT that took up half a building the
computer in your cell phone today is a
million times cheaper and a thousand
times more powerful that's a billion
fold increase in price performance of
computing since I was an undergraduate
by 2029 and I've been quite consistent
on this date we will have completed the
reverse engineering at the human brain
and we're already made very good
progress on that we've reverse
engineered a number of different regions
like the cerebellum which is responsible
for our skill formation and slices of
the cerebral cortex where we do our
recursive thinking and the auditory
cortex the visual cortex and so on by
2029 we'll have reverse-engineered and
modeled and simulated all the regions of
the brain and that will provide us the
software algorithmic methods to simulate
you know all of the human brain's
capabilities including our emotional
intelligence and computers at that time
will be far more powerful than the human
brain and we'll be able to create
machines that really do have the
subtlety and suppleness of human
intelligence and they'll combine that
power with ways in which machines
already superior to us they can harness
all of human knowledge with a few
keystrokes it can
member billions of things accurately
they can share knowledge electronic
speeds that are a million times faster
than the human language so it'll be a
very powerful combination but the last
point I'll make is that it's not some
alien invasion of intelligent machines
coming from artists to invade us it's
coming from within our civilization and
the whole point of it is to extend our
reach ever since we picked up a stick to
reach a higher branch we have used our
tools to extend our reach we can now
already extend our reach mentally I can
take out device from my pocket and
access all of human knowledge with a few
keystrokes half the farmers in China
have these devices and can do the same
thing it is pointing a real Cultural
Revolution in China and around the world
and these tools are continued to grow
exponentially in power the singularity
is not just that point where we achieve
human level of intelligence and machine
and that will start a new revolution
where these machines will continue to
grow exponentially in power they'll be
able to actually improve their own
software design by 2045 we'll have
expanded the intelligence of our human
machine civilization a billion fold that
will be singularity we borrowed this
metaphor from physics to talk about an
event horizon it's hard to see beyond
well it's not the case
I'm only looking at the optimistic side
I mean I am an optimist and I do think
we've been helped more than we've been
hurt by technology already human life
expectancy was 37 in 1800 and human life
was very hard disaster-prone labor
filled disease filled and so on but I've
actually written extensively about the
dangers of all this bill Joy's article
on the cover of Wired magazine while the
future does need us which talked about
the grave dangers of genetics
nanotechnology and robotics
came from my book he said he says at the
beginning of the article he got these
ideas from my book at the age of
spiritual machines and chapter 8 of the
singularity's nears is called the deeply
intertwined promise versus peril of GNR
genetics nanotechnology and robotics I'm
working extensively with the army to
develop a rapid response system to deal
with the possible abuse of biotechnology
so about the same technologies that are
empowering us to reprogram biology away
from cancer and heart disease could also
be used by a bioterrorist to reprogram a
biological virus to be more deadly or
more communicable and the good news is
we actually have the scientific tools to
defend ourselves
just like we defend ourselves from
software viruses with a rapid response
system and we need to put a system like
that in place but it's up it's not
accurate to say that I'm only painting a
rosy future and that I have a utopian
vision my vision is not utopian the
power of these technologies will grow
exponentially I believe that is
inexorable that has gone on for the last
110 years since the 1890 census what we
do with these technologies is not
preordained that future history has not
been written I am very concerned about
the downsides I've written extensively
about them and in fact I'm working on on
defending against those I am optimistic
that we will get more promise than peril
but they both exist technology has been
a double-edged sword
ever since fire and stone tools
well I've been very active in talking
about the down side of technology and
there are dangers a danger we face right
now is the ability for a bioterrorist to
use our biological sciences to reprogram
a biological virus to be deadly or
communicable and we have the ideas to
combat that but if they're not yet in
place and so I think that's an
existential risk we need to deal with
very quickly there will be new dangers
from these new technologies I mean I'm
optimistic but not sanguine and I'm not
necessarily convinced that we won't
encounter painful episodes I think
overall we'll be helped more than we're
heard but I mean you don't have to look
at the 20th century we had 180 million
people die in the wards of the 20th
century that scale of destruction was
made possible by technology we've also
helped ourselves enormous Lee because
human life expectancy was 48 in 1900 so
we need to address these these dangers
and downsides I mean that's what worries
me